Paulie Malignaggi the former world
champion boxer Showtime boxing analyst
as I mentioned he's been a sparring
partner about Conor McGregor Paulie kind
enough to join me here on the show good
morning Paulie how are you man long in
case are they going I'm good so Paulie I
have to shave my head
if Conor McGregor wins this fight ah you
know me am I in some trouble here I
can't make the call like that you know
I'm not a psychic but you know you I
think you favor Floyd Mayweather even
it's a kind of a burger is doing some
good things in game okay so I know that
sparring is usually sacred but what can
you tell us about how Conor McGregor
looks in his first campaign camp rather
as a boxing up spar you know he's coming
along you know he works hard every day
so obviously progress will be there
Lydia very dedicated person um can't get
into the ins and outs but of course it's
it's it's not going to be your typical
as I said Saturday night during Garcia
after the Garcia bonafide you thought
it'll break my gr CA with all those
perfect fundamentals and it's perfectly
in position in your perfect balance he's
going to be able to update all four in a
bit uh you know the creative I'll play
it that way you know as far as what he
wants to do and how you want to do it
and uh normal it works you know it's
it's something that is trying to
perfecting camp up and out and we'll see
how a cow comes on fight night Paul
you've uh you've done my boxing podcast
before and when this fight was announced
you were very much saying that that they
whether by a landslide mayweather is
going to dominate a fight like that
after working in his camp
do you have any different opinion of
Conor McGregor I mean listen you still
has a fair Floyd Mayweather it's not
very easy fight for Conor found resolve
against it but Conor evening I have
O'Connor is that I see dedication is
already working every day and I see he's
serious about this you know he didn't
just do this sort of payday at UFC
series about student locked up said
everything he would love to get this win
and might be a monument would be a
monumental result for him you know so he
would he would love nothing more than to
do all this but of course it's a you
know you fearful in Mayweather but it's
a it's something that Conor relishes
relish the challenge and that's
kind of wife say I respect him a little
more after being camp with him you'd say
I did this game faces for real
is there any part of this flight poly
where you say that McGregor has
advantage oh the only small of energy to
talk about is probably the fact that
there's probably things that McGregor
does in May where that hasn't seen
before now does that mean that kind of
water control that doesn't necessarily
mean they're going to work I mean you
know bringing any guy ashrita box and
he's going to have a different sense of
time you're different rhythms so
obviously there's many of them use
accessible you know so you know
McGregor's go over here has to be to use
the awkwardness to his advantage in ways
that will actually work against that
memory defenses and they'll other
intelligence and they will have style
and you know because he's been a fighter
his whole life McGregor even if he not
been a boxer I think he at least has the
foundation of know knowing and
understanding certain concepts even if
they're not boxing and understanding
certain concepts and if you take those
concepts into the old right situation
and use a certain amount of awkwardness
to get the time in correct
you know there's could be small issues
or being the early on and then you know
that's all of that like very mean to
this punching power small issues
congruent to bigger issues if he knows
how to translate those into bigger
issues see we shall see people have used
Paulie Marcos Maidana as kind of a
blueprint for Conor McGregor it
unorthodox chopping style do you see
that as being a blueprint for him um I
wouldn't say that word living in Maidana
was stored I've been boxing for life you
know I wouldn't exactly it's like that
you know but of course you know there's
definitely some more stuff in there I
mean we've we've boxed and you know it's
definitely it can also get rough in
there and you know the thing about it is
though a lot of stayin just a few rounds
you can have to keep you to create it
because you know and I don't know that
through out of 12 rounds five ones
member adjust how many possible work
into the regular base to a boxing ring
you know but feeling that would be my
only concern really well be one of my
concerns is O'Connor Beach he's got this
handful of things that he wants to do
with us too
few rounds a good boxer time phasing out
so then do you have anything else you
can go to have you learned and often
boxing with less who wants to go to
point B C and B and that's kind of one
of the things that you know gets tricky
Joe Cortez the former referee he said I
believe yesterday that things got a
little bit rough with you and McGregor
that true yeah yeah I'll be honest on ma
it was uh he got a little rough I got a
little kind she got all you got I'd say
you know thirty very very dirty even
inspiring us
I don't think he was uh you know he
bring the game face into spine
um it's not very likable um I got a
better like avoid a lot of times in NFS
or world so so you know it would also
they're hidden words in the media about
week said about each other before we
even came to camp so I'm sure it all
came to a head on in the spine I'm sure
to come through it again today inspiring
it I'm not here to be friends or anybody
and um he went here I've certainly seen
the way he's been with us more long does
he definitely on your views to be
friends many responders so so by that by
that uh equation I expect another good
one say I think the question Polly is
that the people have is if it gets away
from Conor McGregor will we see him kind
of devolve into an MMA fighter and try
some of that stuff I know there are huge
financial penalties if he does but you
mentioned there was some dirty stuff in
sparring would it surprise you if
McGregor went and no threw an elbow at
Mayweather a kickin mayweather at some
point I wouldn't go that far for a kick
or an elbow on and you can sneak in
elbows even a real boxing match and I
rather think elbows from boxing sales
and in boxing actually really distinct
toes and I need or kick not so much you
can really see the links or again call
it um I don't know it's kind of obtained
to figure out if you know that things I
did you know you get away with those
things or not I could see McGregor
definitely kind of bend the rule a
little bit but yet do within the within
the bounds of a dirty boxer because if
you go over the bounds of the dirty
boxes without like al intentionally just
want words on
unintentionally you risk such that we
find is not working so I think I think
you eat all the line so to speak but you
to align with the awkwardness until
maybe a little bit very dirty stuff but
you gotta make sure that it's within the
bounds of boxing otherwise you're eating
our power so you're working with them
now how much longer are you gonna spend
with them um I assume the rest of camp
you know I was brought back in yesterday
for after I was at work Percy a burner
last week so actually they told me they
didn't need me for a while so I even
packed up some suits for a fight week
with it all you know we work with sky
shows on what I week so so actually I'm
not leaning back to us right so am I
gonna have to shave my head
seriously I need to know it's simply on
the spot like this but yeah I guess ed
you your favorite maybe wasn't go from
there
hey Polly good luck out there men always
great to catch up with you keep up the
great work
my pleasure cuz i'll see if i week thank
you
Paulie Malignaggi the former world
champion the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience